quel alain trannoy économistes bonsoir
alain 3,1 à merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france que traduisent ces
chiffres annoncés par l' agence centrale
des organismes de sécurité sociale selon
vous bonsoir
ces chiffres sont tout sauf surprenant
les français étaient pour la une par une
part importante d'entre eux ne pouvaient
pas aller produire et il pouvait pas
aller consommer donc les pas étonnant
dans ces conditions que les embauches
étaient soit revenu disons à la plus
simple expression
c'est tout à fait dans l'ordre des
choses maintenant la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir si ce mouvement va
s'arrêter ou est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
reprise progressive des embauches dans
les mois à venir
alors justement c'était ma question
suivante effectivement l'activité
économique a repris véritablement est
encore un papa totalement le 11 mai
selon vous peut-on s'attendre un
meilleur bilan dans les mois qui
arrivent quel est votre pronostic même
si j'imagine vous n'avez pas de boule de
cristal mais je pense que le mois
d'avril représente un point bas et qu'on
va assister dans les mois à venir et
d'abord pour le mois de mai je dirais à
des chiffres moins mauvais mais on sera
pas du tout encore non distillation de
retour à la normale et il faut
s'attendre à ce que le chômage en france
soit ils ont beaucoup plus haut cette
année en 2020 et encore sans doute
également 2021
ce n'est peut-être qu'en 2022 qu'on
retrouvera le niveau d'activité qu'on
avait en 2019 donc c'est une situation
totalement inédite qui n'a pas
d'équivalent depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale avec je dirais une baisse
d'activité économique
le gouvernement prévoit 8 % ça peut
facilement aller à 10 % 10 % de baisse
il faut remonter disons 1 seconde guerre
mondiale pour avoir un une faiblesse
aussi important de l'activité économique
donc je dirais que pour les deux
prochaines années nous attendre à une
situation du marché de l'emploi dégradée
et donc il faut donc accompagner en
terme de retour à l'emploi en termes de
subvention à la création d'entreprise
les subventions à à la création
d'emplois al embauche au moma en 2010
tom 2008 moment du 10 honda présidence
de nicolas sarkozy au moment de la
grande crise financière
il y a eu je dirais des subventions à
l'embauché qui ont été un plan de
subventions la bouche qui a été élaboré
et deux économistes ont étudié à fond
qu'elle a été l'efficacité de ce plan de
subventions à l'embauché et ils ont
montré que ça avait permis l'embauché de
300 mille personnes donc je pense que
c'est peut-être encore un petit peu tôt
parce que finalement il faut que la
situation sony sanitaires soient
assainis mais on peut penser qu'à partir
de septembre
ça serait bien qu'il y est je dirais en
même temps que qui ré dbz qui restent
importantes en termes de de maintien à
l'emploi des travailleurs existent en
particulier les cdi
mais pour ré encourager l'embauché des
cdd pourrait encourager l'embauché des
jeunes parce que je rappelle qu'au mois
de septembre
c'est toute une nouvelle génération de
jeunes diplômés qui va venir sur marché
du travail
il est donc indispensable d'accompagner
cette arrivée par des conditions
financières beaucoup plus favorable pour
les entreprises de permet de façon à
permettre quand même une embauche de
cette nouvelle génération
et faire en sorte qu'elles soient pas
sacrifiées sur marché du travail merci à
vous à l'impro noah nous avoir apporté
votre analyse en direct sur rt francs